and tonight we are nearing the end of
what was one of the single worst days of
biden's presidency so far now after 357
other terrible days that is saying a lot
breaking this afternoon a 6-3 decision
as we predicted the u.s supreme court
they blocked biden's vaccine mandate on
private businesses just three days after
it went into effect and while the court
did upheld uphold an hhs requirement for
hospital workers of course that's
medicare medicaid federal money the
federal mandate on private businesses is
no more it is a massive win for freedom
for
private businesses for medical privacy
and so much more we'll have a lot more
coming up on it tonight biden's bad day
did not stop there at 1 p.m joe he
meandered wandered over to the capitol
in a desperate attempt to persuade his
former colleagues in the senate to end
the filibuster once and for all
something he has been opposed to his
entire career up until now now he wants
the power grab just before he arrived
however democratic senator from arizona
kristin cinema bravely frankly delivered
a speech on the senate floor
completely rejecting joe's demands a
short time later democratic senator joe
manchin echoed her remarks stating quote
as i have said many times before i will
not vote to eliminate or weaken the
filibuster in other words joe's field
trip was pointless even before he
stepped foot on capitol hill now this is
a level frankly a public humiliation
that's kind of hard to watch now
needless to say joey joey was not happy
he needed some ice cream perhaps take a
look
one thing for certain times
every other
major civil rights bill that came along
if we missed the first time
we could come back and try it a second
time
we missed this time
we missed this time
and the state legislative bodies
continue to change the law not as to who
can vote
who gets to count the vote
count the vote
count the vote
it's about election subversion
not just whether or not people get to
vote
who
counts the vote
anyway ironically his state of delaware
where he served 575 000 years he never
once tried to make voting more
accessible and they have some of the
most restrictive voting laws in delaware
he never lifted a finger and by the way
we are at the point where we do need to
seriously ask
frankly is joe biden okay
he doesn't look okay he doesn't act okay
he looks like a shell of his former self
he looks like he's deteriorating before
our very eyes both mentally and
physically and frankly the people around
him are not doing him any favors
covering all of this up and hiding him
he's confused he has memory loss weird
outbursts of anger uh quite a lot of
difficulty finding words the the thing
the thing you know the thing he has
trouble walking those are symptoms of
someone who is not doing well where are
the people in his life that care about
him and love him and as for the
filibuster the senate rule that joe
referred to as a racist relic of jim
crow well today democrats they use the
very same filibuster to kill a bill from
ted cruz that would put sanctions on
russia now if there was ever a moment in
time that perfectly encapsulated the
democrats bewildering level of hypocrisy
that's it by the way as by the way as a
side note they used the filibuster over
300 times last year now a few uh hours
earlier back at the white house joey was
in the his happy place a weird fake oval
office set this this is bizarre you know
he has a real oval office but he goes to
the oval office set where he loves to
give speeches from a miniature oval
office desk and today's speech was
supposed to be about his big plan to
battle omicron the variant which he has
been rip which has been ripping through
this country for weeks record numbers of
covet positive
cases unlike anything we've seen
unfortunately joe had a lot of trouble
communicating that plan to you the
american people i'll let you decide take
a look
now i don't like to uh
you know
outline the next steps we're taking
against
i'd like to outline the next steps are
taken against over on the uh the omicron
variant and to help uh lead our federal
testing program
i've talked i've i've taught i've
excused me i've tapped uh dr tom
i hope i pronounced it and angel
ingalls me
correct is that right jeff
sorry just talking like joe needless to
say uh still a lot of questions about
biden's covert 19
disaster but today like almost every day
joe could not be bothered to answer any
of these questions take a look
thank you for taking the time
message for vaccinated americans who are
wondering why they should continue to
restrict their activities given your
health officials say most americans will
get covet at some point
folks we'll talk about that later come
on
he usually says but they won't let me
i'm not allowed to get in trouble every
time i take a question anyway a year ago
you know for a full year 2020 joe was
bragging he shut down that virus
he didn't he said not having enough
tests was a travesty he said president
trump should not remain as president
because of 220 000 cova deaths well
almost twice that amount died since
biden took over with more american
deaths from covert in 2021 under his
watch than 2020 when we knew next to
nothing when we first got this thing now
joe thinks that by the way by the he
thinks it's 20 20. pathetic but it's
true
now a very frail looking president biden
is unable to answer a single question
about covert 19 as this virus continues
to rage throughout the entire country we
are now living what is an ultimate sad
predictable preventable nightmare
according to a new poll from news nation
a large majority of americans disapprove
of biden's handling of covet 19. keep in
mind even before this horrendous day for
president joe biden he was already
polling at an all-time low yesterday's
quinnipiac poll had him at a 33 percent
approval rating with inflation at
seven percent that is a four decade high
a 40 year high and now is planned to
eliminate the filibuster that's dead
buildback broke is dead his so-called
voting rights legislation is dead uh his
vaccine mandate is all but dead as well
as the supreme court now is moving
put their ruling forward things are
going so poorly over at the white house
that reporters in the media mob are now
openly wondering if biden and harris
will even bother running for another
term and get this today kamala harris
herself she had a disastrous interview
she couldn't even answer that simple
question you decide take a look are we
going to uh to see the same democratic
ticket in 2024
i'm sorry we are thinking about today i
mean honestly i i know why you're asking
the question because
this is the part of the punditry and the
gossip around places like washington d.c
let me just tell you something we're
focused on the things in front of us
okay that would be in front of you is
that a no why are you unable to answer
that question kamala harris do you have
some reason to believe that joe biden
will not be able to run for reelection
do you think he's not capable of being
president do you think you're not
capable of serving in the white house
well we'll have so much more from that
train wreck interview coming up later in
the program but
what's uh going on here of course i
think we all know the answer joe biden
is a cognitive wreck it's more apparent
than ever probably will not be running
for reelection many people wondering if
he can even finish the next three years
of this term and meanwhile kamala harris
is totally completely utterly out of her
league and incompetent members of her
own staff refer to her as a
soul-destroying bully they've been
leaving in droves they say she's too
lazy to read briefing materials and then
she's lashing out at others when she's
painfully unprepared i don't know who's
going to be on the democratic ticket in
2024 but if they wanna any chance of
winning the dnc would be wise to kick
dumb and dumber here to the curb
but i don't think hillary is the answer
either